[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
ah what a lad well this is it guys today
we are lucky enough to be joined by one
of the greatest players in the modern
era he's a one club man at all levels of
the game having starred for canterbury
absolutely dominated for the crusaders
and has forced his way into the all
black ten jersey more often than not and
along the way he's won almost everything
possible multiple times including five
super rugby titles he is an incredible
player and somehow even a better lad it
is one of the greatest to do it richie
moana welcome brother
cheers oh [ __ ] what an intro
oh good thanks for having me bro
mate stoked to have you on it's always
good to be in the presence of greatness
so mate no better than you at the moment
so stoked to have you on no it's um
sort of memories go back to
you know the
early what a lad days of uh pranks of
fletcher smith i think that headman
[Laughter]
had me in stitches so
i'm glad i'm here for a um
you know a potty not
not for a prank
unless you got something planned but no
i remember you hitting me up in the
changing rooms i think it was after um
the silesi jaunty one and you came up to
me saying that you were loving it
but ever since i just wanted to get you
on no i appreciate it thanks for having
me man so anyway how's the break been
you've got an extended break from super
rugby how's how's that been yeah it's
good bro it's um
it's really nice to be home and i guess
uh with the circumstances with the lads
heading to queenstown it's sort of
it was a good fit i'm not having to
leave home and um
you know spending time with my two wee
ones and my wife so
it's been good but um you know how it is
when you're watching and you get sort of
itchy feet wanting to be out there with
the lads
um you know it does get a bit hard but
really excited to you know to hopefully
jump back in soon may you definitely be
catching up with some family time
obviously you had a long nds tour
hard hard to be away from the family for
that long but um you're probably making
up for that now yeah it is tough and um
you know everyone had to go through it
um and it was sort of kind of unique
because you know the all blacks hadn't
for a long time gone through something
like that um
and i i had a baby just before i left
little mali was
was two days when i left to go over to
oz
so that was tough and had his challenges
leaving leaving family behind but
making the most of it now and just yeah
just enjoying uh you know being a dad
and and seeing them sort of grow
100
did you miss the pre-season i know a lot
of guys are stoked when they get out of
pre-season but did you did you miss it
at all or you're pretty happy just
sitting back
i'm someone that sort of enjoys the sort
of the hard work and the mahi um so i
was sort of doing my own work
but yeah you kind of miss it being in
with the lads and
you know what it's like um
you know the bonds start off early in
pre-season and the work that you're
doing it just sort of binds
sort of the connections uh stronger and
as tough as it is
you know your memorable moments and
memories sort of come in pre-season and
how sort of [ __ ] and tough all that work
is and how's your body now are you
feeling good feeling ready to go bro i'm
ready eh i'm ready um i just can't wait
to sort of rip in but
at the same time it's been quite nice
just sort of taking a step back um
sort of when super rolls around
you know we'll kind of just get chucked
in and
you kind of ride in the thick of it for
you know the whole season so
it's good to sort of step back and i'm
enjoying seeing um
you know other players lead and just
seeing
things from a different perspective and
you know obviously with ferg and simon
just loving the way that they're going
and
you know it's going to be
tough coming back in and trying to sort
of um
climb my way back or trying to
earn the jersey again so
that's a challenge i'm looking forward
to but yeah i can't wait to get get back
in mate how stacked is your side and
especially your back line at the
crusaders
you guys still have heaps of guys to
return and at the moment it looks like
you guys are just on another level still
yeah it's
it's um we're pretty spoiled for choice
um
you know and
you know especially the outside backs i
think it's the hardest place to sort of
pick at the moment you guys got guys
like lester
who played the way he did in the weekend
and um
you still got you know classy outside
back on the bench you know like civil
rights last weekend so
um was support for choice but
um
guys are pretty
they they're pretty grounded and we know
how quick things can change if you don't
perform one week
which is a challenging thing playing
in our team because
it can cost you a spot on the bench or
it might mean you might have to have a
week a week a week of rest which is
which is niggly but it's just the way it
is
um you know the highest level and being
in a competitive
team
so when is your return
uh hoping to come back for chiefs um
chiefs or blues um
chiefs the earliest but
yeah hopefully it's just been a bit
tough you know there's
there's only a handful of us at the
moment training back here so
uh not able to get sort of you know the
contact i need or sort of game like
situations uh which is tough but
it'd be nice to see some of the boys uh
after this week when they come back so
yeah it'll be good maybe good for
everyone to see you back out there doing
your thing and doing what you've been
doing on this competition for the last
five years absolutely killing it but
like it on every episode we need to hear
the journey back from the start i know
you're a proud cantabrian
give us the rundown on what your
childhood was like
yeah i'd say um
yeah my i had an awesome childhood
awesome upbringing um
a family of six and uh born and raised
in christchurch which i'm really proud
of it's quite funny whenever
boys ask me or or they ask you know
where i was born
they just assume i was born in auckland
or something and then moved to
christchurch
but i'm one of the few one of the few
brown brothers actually born down here
in christchurch
which i'm proud of um
but yeah just grew up
in a loving family and a supportive
family and my dad was
was a code head and
basically gave me no choice or option
but to play footy and
for that i'm really grateful for but you
know earliest childhood memories was him
taking me to
my registration my club registration
and um
yeah playing for marist albion
and uh grew up in apricothian here in
christchurch and i went to rickett high
year nine
and then had the opportunity to go to
san andreas college on a rugby
scholarship
which was good timing uh because i think
the wheels are falling off uh i was
really only going to school to eat my
lunch and
and check the ball around but um
yeah i think it was a sort of a lifeline
for me to
sort of pursue my rugby career and take
things a bit seriously so
uh you went to stack
and then um
yeah leaving school just joined the
academy uh for canterbury and
not long after made my debut for
canterbury in
2013
which was just an awesome time to join
the franchise and sort of
have a little glimpse of what um
you know being the canopy rugby player
was about because you had such awesome
role models there at the time like andy
alice
you know nasimanu i remember who was a
huge part of um
you know the culture
um you know you're adam whitelock and
tom taylor's and tyler blondel was the
likes it was awesome to
be in a team with those um those players
and
um
you know you kind of
it just flashes by you and then you know
a couple years later you're kind of the
players that
um you're kind of like the tom taylor of
the team you know you've been there for
five years six years and you've got new
kids coming up so
amongst that just the whole heap of
footy and um
crusaders and and just sort of climbing
my way through the ranks and trying to
i guess sort of make my mark in the in
the canterbury in crusader's jersey so
going back to your school days did was
there a
time where you thought that rugby was
going to be a career for you and is that
sort of why you moved to
um saint andrews oh bro i think like
to be honest like
from his
from his father like
as far as i can remember i was always
going to be a rugby player
i was always going to be where i am now
i wasn't arrogant or cocky but i had
this confidence that i knew that i could
do it
from a young age
um
you know i'd say mostly because i was so
passionate about rugby like i actually
just loved footy i love the crusaders
and i love
the all blacks and just watching rugby
with my old man and my brothers and um
every spare minute just kicking the ball
like i loved it and
i think because of that i always knew i
would sort of do whatever it took to
um to be at
this level and to play for crusaders and
hopefully one day being all black um so
yeah i'd say from a young age
that's so cool so so did your touch
background uh have anything to do with
your rugby career because i know you're
very good at touch yeah it's it's funny
like i i knew from a young age you know
from six or seven that i always wanted
to to be a crusader in an all black
but touch didn't
i didn't start playing touch until i was
year 10 you know until i was 15 16.
um and that was only due to going to san
andreas college who
who were pretty good at touch in the
mixed grades
so i'd say touch had a huge influence on
sort of adding bits to my game adding
adding tools to my toolbox in terms of
my catch pass
my vision
quick feed and acceleration and
and all that stuff and everything else
but
yeah i just absolutely love touch bro i
think it's just um
you know one of those games that
i still say now you know if it was
professional i think i'd be playing
touch you know i just loved it that much
um
you know mainly because the fact that i
didn't have to make a tackle
not that i made any not going to make
any
tackles at the moment but
i think i just loved it because of the
flare and
you know i was able to express myself
bro and it was awesome that you know it
gave me that sort of freedom to do that
which i do get in rugby often um
but yeah just i just love the
competitiveness and um
the dynamics of the game you know where
people think touches quite
you know pass the ball around but um you
know it's very
strategic um you know for those that
have played it at a you know high level
yeah it's such a cool game so underrated
for rugby development couldn't agree
anymore yeah
and so is it true that you missed out on
the new zealand schools at the end of
your school schooling year yeah bro yeah
yeah i did i um
i went to the schools trial uh which was
up north
and um
we had like a schools camp
and like
you know there was some big buffer zero
you know you like your jackson garden
bishop and and guys you just
you know when you're you're playing in
the south island and you're you're like
a smaller school and you just hear the
names of like
man these are the next big guys that are
gonna you know um yeah that are gonna
take over footy
and um
you know it's quite daunting when you're
going from a little school
or even when you're just a south island
schoolboy um
because these guys are giants bro you
know these guys are
um
they're just the head of you know the
game in terms of like their builds and
just the way they play so i went to the
trial and
um if i remember i remember getting like
i remember getting stitched up big time
mail i got 10 minutes in the
oh true
and um
but i still like even like now i feel
inside i'm real bitter about it you can
tell i'm like
um
i've got like 10 minutes bro and like
they called you know that was full time
and i was like five even get a crack man
um
but yeah eventually like a week later i
got the phone call
saying that um
yeah or hey look uh richie like
um yeah you didn't make the the team and
blah blah blah and you know whatever was
said after that i can't remember
but like i just remember like my heart
dropping bro like you know like
like it was like i was being told that
like i actually can't pursue my rugby
career anymore yeah like that's how
serious it was for me like that's how
bad i wanted to make this team
um
and i remember even back then of hearing
stats of like those who make schools
um there's a percentage of those guys
that make the 20s and then if you play
20s you're guaranteed pretty much to
play super rugby yeah
so like man all these stats are going
through my head man and i'm just like
farm so go today
um
you know eventually i'm i'm in tears
um about not making the school's team
but
um
i'd probably say you know it was
probably the best thing that happened to
me at that stage and
sort of didn't make me any more
motivated but um just kind of knew i had
to sort of keep sort of grafting away
really yeah because i guess you had that
confidence that you're always going to
get there and i suppose that was
probably your first setback of your
journey to become that professional
rugby player that you always knew you
would so um interesting to hear how you
handled that yeah yeah well it's just
you know it's just kind of um as you
said it was sort of my first setback of
like far out like i didn't make this
team
um what does that mean for me now um
which is ridiculous you know i was
already 18 years old you know uh yeah
looking back eh
looking back you can order
but um
you know
talking to
my first 15 coach at the time and he was
just like you know it's
it's one man's opinion um
you know literally one man's opinion um
and he said to me i remember you know
cream always rises to the top
um so he was saying this to me on the
phone kind of sort of like comforting me
and meanwhile on my head i'm like shut
up man
i don't want to hear this
that doesn't that doesn't mean anything
to me right now did you not just hear
what i said i didn't make the team bro
[Music]
um but yeah you look back in at those
moments and um
you know a whole heap of other moments
too that sort of i don't know
shape you to who you are so how did you
go from missing out on new zealand
skills to the following year being into
the canterbury
uh npc side one of the powerhouse sides
of the comp oh bro i don't it was um
it it all happened quite fast day so i
went to a club called um lynnwood here
in in christchurch and
i remember
sort of my last year of school going
around to clubs asking um
sort of what the club was like and and
where do they see me playing next year
in their club side and
just kind of having those discussions
and
i was always certain my last year school
that i was going to play senior rugby
the year after
you know looking back bro i was like 75
kg he's not not much
smaller than what i am now
and i just come out of school
and um
i just was certain i was i'm going to
play senior rugby out i don't care where
it is
but i'm so determined to just play
senior rugby because i think i can and i
think i'm good enough
and so like i kid you not i went around
to
five or six clubs literally saying to
them i want to play senior rugby here
and every coach
and every
rdo said to me
you're too small
[Music]
and that we see you playing colts uh
before you before you make your way to
seniors like we've actually got a 10
who's playing seniors he's handy
play a few games of colts and then you
can move your way up
and um i was just like nah
nah man stuff
i was like no no way
um
so it's funny i went to
i had a meeting with
our tech coach now for the crusaders his
name scott henson
and uh he was the head coach of loomwood
at the time
and so i had a meeting with him and he
said if you're good enough you're old
enough you know and he just
basically said that um yeah if i'm good
enough i'll play in the senior team
for longwood which was like the last
team i wanted to play for
um
you know
and it turns out sort of a
you know they didn't have really numbers
to feel the senior team so they just
needed anyone and everyone
pretty much so
it was it was good for me to to join
that club and
um
yeah i just had a pretty good season
with lynnwood
which sort of um put me in the mix for
canterbury now you must absolutely
carved it up to go from not being able
to get a um starting spot for a
cliffside to starting for canterbury or
playing for
yeah like it it did happen fast bro i
i played my first game for linwood and
we played sydney
who won who won it the year before
and so our first game and it was my
first senior game
and we played at rugby park
and um
i just had like five everything went my
way like i just couldn't believe i
scored uh 32 points that game
in my debut
and um i think it's got a hat trick and
a couple of kicks and stuff like that
and um
for me it was just that feeling of like
i knew i was right i knew i was
able to play at this level
and i knew i was you know deserving to
be there and that was just
sort of made me more hungry to
to keep performing well and then
which led to me being in the in in the
canterbury mix once they had injuries
and
colin slade was getting caught up to the
all blacks every
you know every couple weeks
which gave me an opportunity and were
you still really confident in your
ability going into the canterbury lineup
did you did you think you were good
enough to be in there as well
um no that sort of changed a because you
know when you're in with the big fishes
you're kind of like oh [ __ ] man like
you know like i was just lit i just left
school man and and now i'm here with you
know like a tyler blinddale and tom
taylor um
robbie throwing um adam white like you
johnny mcnichol you got all these guys
that
um
who'd been there for a long time
i was just sort of more
keen to learn
[Music]
but it was it was cool like
i played
i played nine games that year
[Music]
and we won we won that that year which
was really cool a cool introduction to
sort of mpc
um
yeah just i just love today
and then your form from that is that
what got you into the new zealand 20s
yeah i'd say i'd say i think you know
with 20s and with um
you know they look at players that are
you know it's they can't help but look
at players that are really playing at
npc level you know like a
you know you had simon hickey without
twenty's team he was captain he was
playing for blues bra and he was ripping
it up you know he was
i vividly remember him and tavita lee
were in our 20s team but
they were putting on a show with with
the blues
and um anton was another one who was
with the chiefs
um
so that all sort of
just sort of led uh you know one thing
to another
with making those teams and just sort of
um
putting in some work but
the 20s thing was was pretty cool and we
we bombed it and now in our year we lost
it at home
in the semis against south africa but
it was a cool experience and you kind of
knew that oh yeah this is definitely
what i want to do and
definitely what i'm you know capable of
doing yeah i remember playing against
you i spoke about it on damien's one but
um we were playing with hurricanes
development you were you were the 10 for
the 20s but even back then you were so
classy everything you did was silky
smooth and
it was obvious you're going to have a
big future after i saw that
i remember i thought i remember you
there was like a mike mike kainga was
playing
um
bro yeah you just yeah things like that
you just um
you know be a part of your career you
think well at the time 20s is massive um
but it's a good lesson in like terms of
when you think something's really
important of just having another
perspective of you know the true meaning
behind it or that's not your everything
or if it doesn't go well it's not the
end of the world and i think
20s was the same you know i made the
team but i wasn't the starting first
five i still wasn't where i wanted to be
so it just sort of gave me more
motivation to keep training hard and
razer was your coach then 2a
yeah bro yep so he he was our coach in
2013 for canterbury and uh he was coach
with 20s with
chris boyd and
rangy
um
so he had a pretty good coaching side so
you've obviously had played a lot of
footy under scott robinson how
how's your relationship with him what's
he like as a coach um
it's funny like that's
my whole professional career i've had
him as a coach bar one year which was
super rugby my first super rugby
my first supreme season which was in
216.
so apart from that season i've had him
as a coach basically all the way through
my professional career so
like i'm really lucky and grateful for
like our relationship because we've just
been on this journey together and
when i was starting out as a player like
he was stunned as a super rugby coach
too so
we have a real honest relationship it's
it's um
it's really honest that's
you know he he's real demanding on what
he wants from me as a player and you
know i have the same for him as a coach
and
he's just really cool it's i think what
you see is what you get with ray
you know people have a lot of opinions
and
different things to say about him which
is
which is cool and funny but i think one
thing about raises
a lot of people underestimate him sort
of technically as a coach
and just sort of how good he is and um
just the vision that he has for for his
teams it's pretty special to be part of
those teams and to be
in that culture and in their atmosphere
and
seeing him every day in his uh in his
work
and the results speak for themselves to
be fair don't they mate you guys i think
you've won it every year since you two
have formed your combination and the
super rugby so it's a pretty impressive
uh pretty impressive run yeah it's it's
it's good bro it's fun and
um
i think like he puts in a lot of work
hey you know it's um
you know you see the things on tv and
you know comments he makes or his
personality but
he actually really works hard and um
it's cool to be you know working for
someone and playing for someone that you
know is really honest about his mahi and
about what he's trying to achieve with
the team um
you know
long may it continue that
you know all that and your rise into the
crusaders was pretty rapid as well
wasn't it because in 2015 i think you're
about the fifth or sixth first choice 10
and then the following year 2016 you're
pretty much straight into number one so
what was that rise like for you well it
was crazy eh like i just
like i just never would have imag
imagined that it would have happened
that fast
like i was in the whiter squad in 215
and i had um
i had
carter you're dizzy you had slady
tyler blinddale and tom taylor and then
i was the fifth
uh first five yeah so
yeah no
any stay i didn't even think i was i
knew i wasn't going to get a run that
year i knew i was just there to sort of
learn and hold the tackle pads but
i didn't never imagine that all all four
of them ahead of me would all leave at
the same time
which is just crazy but it sort of threw
me in the deep end and
you know in terms of
all the years that i played rugby 216
was one where i just learned the most
bro like i was just i was humbled pretty
quickly and just um
went through a real rough patch of of
getting beaten up and
just losing games you know we lost you
guys the canes and
um it taught me so many good lessons and
it taught the team good lessons um but
yeah that all happened pretty fast it
was
you know probably wouldn't want it any
other way to be fair it was
it was kind of good yeah did you feel
extra pressure um replacing carter
obviously
canterbury legend and you're you're the
next guy
in that ten jersey was there extra
pressure around that yeah there was man
there's
it's hard you know
big shoes to fill in terms of you know
the greatest of all time
uh has left and now everyone's like oh
man now we got this guy like
it's
um
and i was still trying to find my feet
and still trying to work things out so
um
i guess my personality just sort of
helped because i was so
so driven and so focused on what i
needed to do or how could i be better
and just how driven i was but there was
a lot of outside noise but
to be fair i'm sort of not one that sort
of pays too much attention to that or or
even if i am
i don't really let let it get to me
that much and were you still really
confident that you are still going to be
a successful um driver of this crusader
side even after 2016 where you felt like
there's a lot of learnings
uh yeah i was but
i was definitely certain of that but
i learned some yeah real tough lessons
as i said around you know um
being humbled real you know
being humbled and grounded around
um
not being consistent and and having like
shocking games you know like games where
um i've just been dragged off the field
or i've missed um five goal kicks um in
south africa where
like you just those lessons are so
valuable now like for me
but at the time was just so hard to
learn
because all you want to do is just be
really successful but um
you know those things have just made me
to who i am now but
yeah for sure like it's just it was a
roller coaster but i always knew like
you know
this is you know where i am now this i
always imagine this
it's crazy you obviously learnt really
quick because the next five years have
been the opposite been really successful
you've driven that side
so well over the last few five years
you've i think you've won mvp pretty
much on all of them so
um any sort of standout games or finals
that really stand out for you and your
super rugby career
um
far out man that's tough
like there's so many memorable games and
among some of the titles like
you know at the time when you win them
you're just thinking in your head like
this is the best you know that's the
best feeling
you know and you just can't
replace it um but then
you sort of look back and
one season that in particular that
i think i like the most because of the
journey was
was 217 because it was our first year of
um of winning it and
i guess the journey of going across
johannesburg and playing in that
environment right in that stadium
and we hadn't won it
crusaders hadn't won it since uh 2008
so just that joy of
you've done something that you've
dreamed of um ever since you're a little
kid and to deal with guys that had
won it in 2008 like a white crockett was
just pretty special too
and um
yeah i think i'll always remember that
one just because of the journey of of
watching the hurricanes versus lions
early hours of the morning
and then
just thinking [ __ ] we're on the plane
man
like yeah yeah
there was an emotional rollercoaster of
getting there and then far out
the unknown of
you know there were so many boys that
hadn't played in the final before so
i think that one was pretty special and
they came home hard too didn't they with
even with the red card they were like
coming home
full steam
your last fumes we were hanging we were
hanging on like as you know playing in
high altitude and and
when the crowd gets behind them they're
just unstoppable
you know and had there been another 10
minutes bro you know like i'd say most
of us would say we would have lost bro
like it's just we were hanging on
and that's what made it even more
you know just enjoyable of how hard we
had to work and how much actually hurt
you know you get that sort of taste of
blood in your throat
of just hanging on and um
yeah that was pretty yeah it was a lucky
one and five championships that's five
championship dues um any any indie dudes
that really stand out for you i know you
go good
oh man i'd say um i'd say 219 hey i can
already just say i could just yeah 219.
you know you got the likes of
you know the the older guys that that
are sort of you know um their last
hurrah you know like a ryan crotty
tim bateman
you know howie and rito
their last season with the crusaders
you know that was
that was just memorable in terms of um
yeah just doing it
you know again and and and all that jazz
and the shenanigans that happens after
it's just it's just awesome it's it's i
love it yeah get your goggles on do you
guys pre-order your goals knowing that
you're going to win the comp
nah nah man there's no talk about goku's
nothing hey there's
um
you know razor he's really creative bro
and he's really on to it so
um
he i'm sure he had them just ready just
in case um
you always want to be ready you know
just
for the best possible outcome so
i guess that's what happened and and
thankfully we got to wear them oh did
you what five times how good anyway i'm
keen to hear about your black career as
well and you had quite a unique um start
to your all black career playing against
them before playing with them talk to me
about that and how that whole experience
was oh man it was like um it was it was
pretty weird i guess
in terms of the game
um
you know i never thought i'd be standing
in line sort of arms you know
sort of holding your brothers and your
face in the haka i think that was the
weirdest thing that i've ever
experienced because
you know one it's
you want to be on that side and you want
to be the one performing the haka
um
but it was awesome you know we
i played at um they took in them and
it was actually just a real cool week
because we'd been with the babas and
along with the traditions and and
celebrating that week and um
but knowing that you're going to be
playing against you know the best team
in the world it was just
it was quite funny and i think
i think i was actually you know really
happy the week was the way it was
planned you know you're kind of just
going through and you're celebrating and
you you're doing all these uh events
that the barbarians do which makes the
week
sort of go a bit faster
um and then all of a sudden you're
facing the haka and that was
it was pretty crazy man how loose is the
barbarians is it as loose as people say
bro it is man i think you know i get
the stories you hear
you know they're true in terms of um
the week and the preparation leading up
to the game
um
you know the barbarian's a special club
you know it's what a team that yeah you
got to be invited to play for um
and i think sort of knowing the history
and the traditions of the barbarians
when you get to camp and when you get to
london all you want to do is sort of put
your best foot forward
and sort of um and carry on the
traditions and
i think it's a cool thing about it too
you know the coaches at the time
we're robbie deans and razer
sort of like anything goes because
i think because it's not up to them to
make rules about how the week should
look or
it's not up to them to make new things
up um in terms of preparation because
there's so many teams and so many
players coaches that have gone before
them that have just
that have just done what the barbarians
do and there's been a lot of events and
you know get your fans here the places
you go for dinner and they have
a magician come around and you know then
they have
people singing
um who you thought was a waitress the
whole time
um
so it's just a real sort of like you
know it's real glamorous and like being
in london it's
uh it's pretty cool uh that you get to
deal with you know guys you know but
then guys
from aussie and guys from south africa
and
guys you never thought you'd ever be
playing with
do you get worried while you're on the
person's stuff that week that [ __ ] i'm
gonna i'm gonna struggle this weekend
against you all makes you ever get to
that point bro yeah you do there's a lot
of head noise and there's um
yeah you know there's
i think you do but
you just understand you just understand
the assignment name i think that's just
the best way out possible i can put it
is that you just know that
you know the team you're in
and
sort of the traditions that have gone
before
and
you know it's not been silly and it's
not been um
you know no one's not it's not silly
it's just you're having bears with your
mates you know you're enjoying your time
you're connecting with
someone that's played on the other side
of the world
and who's had a way you know different
upbringing
um
and that's a special thing about the
barbarians is that you know by thursday
you've
you know you've heard everyone's life
story you've you've danced with your
mate you've seen them in some state
and then now you're ready to go and play
a game with them so that's you know
that's a special thing about barbara's
yeah and you're obviously used to it
because you backed up that um week very
well absolutely put on a clinic against
the all blacks um so
what was it like when you're out there
obviously playing with guys that you you
knew very well so
um what was that like
yeah it was it was cool bro because um
obviously you i played against all these
guys i've played with some of them
um
but you just know the challenge of
playing the all blacks and like you
really
you just really want to beat them
because you really want to put um
you just really want to put a good
performance on and
kind of like oh man i should be there
not on this team
um
you know without being to think about it
that's that's just you know how it is
and
you know i just think the opportunity to
play against all blacks was was special
boy and it's
you know to do it at twickenham and to
you know to almost beat them you know i
i still think i'm the one that lost the
game nani ran a short ball and just
and just bowled me over and scored and
that was kind of like their way of
climbing back but
everything before then was all right but
yeah
that's a bit of a bomb of that one and
that wasn't the last time that happened
too nani's he's running a few times
[Laughter]
no yeah they say go away and that's just
the thing you like i've been low on him
a couple of times and it's still the
same
yeah i think you got to go high and just
get steamrolled
i know yeah some of my sevens they i
kind of just wait for them to make the
tackle and then just kind of like assist
um
i'm not a bad assist tackler i'm not
saying that much i'm not bad at
assisting
well they all bought the ball rip they
don't mind the ball
i just got to be the second player in
yeah that's the that's the problem
was it the following week you were then
called into the all blacks and then
playing for the all blacks yeah bro yeah
there was a few of us there was um
yeah mitch drummond and
don bird
dylan hunt you know there was a few of
us that they had played for the bar bars
and then um and then straight after it
was actually quite funny we showered
we showered and then we hopped on the
abs bus to go back to that hotel
after playing it after playing them so
um
yeah that was you know and that was my
first time
being in the environment and thinking
far out you know you've gone from one
week that was just loose as anything
yeah and now you're in the heaviest
camping so yeah
you're just making sure you know
everything's all good and you know
you're not being late to any meetings so
that was cool and did you feel more
comfortable having just played against
him and playing really well against him
did that make the transition a little
bit easier for you
yeah yeah it did it made it a lot easier
and it just
i guess the other thing was i wasn't the
only one you know there was a few other
guys that were just you know that were
going in as well for the first time so
that made it a lot better and
and also the fact that you know you're
in all blacks camp now you know like
this is legit where you want to be like
you don't want to be anywhere else but
here so
you know we
had a good do and had fun time that week
but now you're like okay
i've got to get my i'm going to get my
[ __ ] together now and i'm going to um
you know got to put my best foot forward
here and did that game feel like a test
match what was the preparation like was
it test match week like yeah it was like
it was quite funny because
um
you know you had two different teams you
had a team playing the french barbarians
and so
i remember
we were warming up and and doing our
training around what we're doing that
week but then there was also another
team that was getting ready to play
france
um
so you know it was it was cool i guess
the time just went really quickly
because um
you're constantly learning you're
constantly doing things you're
constantly checking your phone and
setting alarms
and then catching up with guys and you
know
because i remember davey that davey was
already in he was in the all blacks at
that stage
and so i was literally on his case about
everything about you know gee what do we
wear to this or what do we what do we do
here um
you know and it gets a bit like that day
you know it's like your first day of
school you just you're on edge all the
time anxiety levels through the roof i
having
scared of missing a meeting or anything
byron that's i'm the worst say you know
and i just like you know do i wear
clothes shoes or am i good to wear
scuffs
or like
it gets that bad a you know when you
like question everything
and then you're like [ __ ] man steve was
looking at me funnier for that like did
i do something or
um
yeah you know how it's just it's just
all part of it i guess and that whole
learning experience
and after that game did you how did you
feel did you feel like an all black
after that game even though it wasn't a
test
yeah i did i did but i knew it wasn't
the real thing you know for me i just
was like
um
you know i got the opportunity because
um
you know two games are close together
you know had there been a week
or normal weeks preparation i wouldn't
be there you know i was quite realistic
about that about you know i knew i was
there and there abouts but
the situation
and the whole thing meant that i could
be part of it so i was happy man i was
proud
um
you know proud i got an all black number
and you know i was able to put on the
phone and perform the haka
um
but i also knew it was like you know
this is
i didn't want it to end there yeah and
then your first game your first test
match um your debut against argentina
was it or france yeah france france and
dunedin um
down at forsyth and
yeah that was yeah you know you fought
that was in 218 so um
yeah that was a cool moment man like i
had my family down there
um
you know and
i guess that's when you sort of start to
pinch yourself around like you know
you are amongst like you know um some
really classy players and
i think every time i was sort of in the
all blacks environment or in the camp i
just wanted to keep doing enough to make
sure that when the next camp happened i
was
in the conversation or or i was there
training so yeah and what do you like on
the bench first game for the all blacks
sitting on the bench what what are the
nerves like for you
very confident and chilled out customer
but
um all black test match debut nah i'm
not bro i'm not
let's say that i was in all sorts say i
remember um
i came on and broke the i came on
i didn't even know how they made a
substitution in a penalty so we had like
a um
i got subbed on
and the first action was a kick to touch
oh that's true
but they kicked the touch was
so i literally came on
and i was kicking to touch
it but the kick the touch was from
five meters from our line and five
meters from the sideline oh the worst
so it's like
i can't just come on and just like you
know do the leg ones where you just kick
it five meters in front of you
so i gave it a nudge
bro i literally just went out by this
macho
like i was so close i ended up being
ended up being like 45 meters up
but i kicked it and i was just hoping i
was like get out get out
um
luckily it went out i was back then i
was quite notorious for not kicking the
ball out i'm going for it
you're going for it all the time
and um you know it's pretty
you feel pretty um
you feel pretty bad when uh you kick the
ball and all you do is kick it out and
it
stays in field
some of the grounds you get from your
forwards
that's not nice they always say when
you're lying it up just make sure of it
make sure it just get it out
for honesty like that is like the worst
thing you can say to someone that's
about to kick out uh kick the touch like
kick it out yeah
um
yeah
or or when you go for a goal kick
and they're like take your time
yeah
there's certain things that don't help
but
you know you get used to it yeah and one
one massive part of your all black
career today has been your battle with
bodhi for the number 10 jersey um he
only said kind things about you when he
came on the podcast obviously you guys
have a really good relationship how have
you found that battle between you and
him
oh bro it's been awesome like it's um
you know the competition and the
challenges are just like um
you know as i said like you always want
to be at the next camp and you want to
be in the all blacks team and that's the
challenge um that's a big challenge you
know and then you get there and then
there's another challenge and it's
and it's you know going down against you
know
another goat and someone who's
just made his mark massively in the all
black jersey and
you know i'm real respectful of that and
i just love sort of putting my best foot
forward and
you know and making the competition
healthy and
not in a bad way i'm growing him he's
grown me but we know
exactly what
what we need to do to try and to try and
wear the jersey nothing it's just been
something that we've both enjoyed
and um
you know something that has made both of
us better has definitely made me better
and you obviously won the battle to the
ten jersey for the rugby world cup it
was ever a moment uh
leading up to that competition where you
were told that you were going to be
given the ten jersey or was it a weekend
week out
just waiting for the team to be named
no it was it was literally just you're
waiting for the team the team naming and
that's how um
you know that's i think it's a it's a
good thing you just
you're always putting your best foot
forward you're always wanting to try
your best you're always just waiting um
you know to the last minute to know you
know if you get the knot or not and
um
you know i was lucky enough that you
know in the world cup to to get the nod
and
i think
you know
even though body was playing fallback
like man there were so many things and
so many valuable lessons that he was
teaching me uh in the ten jersey and
um times were in the games where he'd be
at ten and i'd be at fallback we're just
we we just somehow ended up in a in that
spot so
uh it was good and it was just something
that like
you know you get nervous about you know
sort of playing against someone like him
makes me nervous you know because you
know
um just how good and how influential he
is for whatever team he's playing that's
cool and how did you find the rugby
world cup what did what'd you make of
the whole experience
bro it was awesome like it's just
you know to be an all-black and then to
play games with all blacks is one thing
but
to be going to a rugby world cup
in the country like japan was just
awesome you know the support
and the experience was awesome um but
you know the lessons we learned on the
field was is just as awesome you know
for me i think those were valuable
lessons and
i'm not disappointed by them but i guess
i'm more just
encouraged that
you know we got a few things wrong but
we were still so close um
but all in all it was an awesome
experience one that
said i'll remember you know forever yeah
what memories do you have from the
england game obviously it was the
disappointing one of the tournament you
guys were looking you obviously looked
really good against ireland the week
before yeah come to england in the
semi-final what do you remember about
that game well i just remember like um
i just remember having the ball a lot
but not going forward
and and
i just remember the constant pressure of
always being driven back in our tackles
um
and almost like kind of looking around
like [ __ ] like what what do we do like
what do we do now um
you know and that was a real tough
lesson to learn on like on that stage
you know it's just you know you wish you
learned these lessons or you wish you'd
thought of something before that game
um
but you know just the way it rolled out
they were better than us
um you know they studied us well man and
they
you know we we did nothing that
surprised them which was um you know was
really disappointing
and how was that to deal with afterwards
are you someone who takes these losses
too hard or are you pretty quick to
bounce on and take the positives from it
and just get back to life yeah i am bro
like um i'm a sore loser like i
you're not used to it i'm real
competitive
i'm
i'm real competitive bro i don't like
losing
um so it was real it was real tough to
experience that and
tough because for me i remember feeling
like i
we didn't just let ourselves down i felt
i genuinely felt like we let you know
the whole of new zealand down and i felt
like man like
it's going to be a long summer
being back home and no one wants us
there like these are thoughts going
through my head you know like
um
i remember you know snapchatting some of
the boys and i was in my room like
dealing you know through sort of comedy
and i was putting these disguises uh on
you know saying like this is how i'm
getting back home so no one recognizes
me
but you know overall like um
i'm pretty quick to to move on otherwise
and um
pretty
you know i'm good enough to sort of
know that um
you know the ones that
the opinions are the ones that matter
most are sort of what really you know
what i care about so and last season you
guys obviously had some really good
performances again
probably let down by a couple towards
the end which probably still hanging
over the side a little bit but what sort
of shape do you think all blacks are in
going forward into this season well i
think um
i think the boys are in a really good
spot like i think
i think
we're just spoiled for choice there's so
many positions where
i think guys are putting their hands up
and um
you know i think what you saw last
season was you know a result of
man it was a long season for the boys
that had been away on tour
um
yeah you know and that's no excuse you
know um
you know we were professional rugby
players and um i think we are definitely
things we could have learned faster and
things we couldn't done could have done
differently but
you know hindsight's beautiful for that
but
i do genuinely believe that
um
have we get those little things right
and have we change this and do this a
bit better um
you know the boys are going to be in
some form you know but what i'm sort of
more excited about are the guys that
sort of stepped up in that you know
end of your tour you know like sort of a
dalton
um
you know and you see glimpses of of
hoskins and
um guys that are still so young but you
know have a lot ahead of them
and
you know with
things done differently and and
um you know just
being a bit more prepared i think these
boys will be uh will be a good we'll be
good to go um exciting times exciting
times ahead and what's what's the plans
for you have you got how long you signed
with new zealand rugby union have you
got much plans ahead of that um
at the moment as of uh now i'm only
signed for this year
um
for 2022 yeah so
um you know hopefully can re-sign
you know through with new zealand rugby
but
at the moment just enjoying my break
it's it's been awesome and
you know when i can get back in that's
when i can start sorting
that stuff out as well are you looking
to stay in new zealand your whole career
um crusaders canterbury man for life or
would you
be tempted to go overseas at some point
yeah i think i think the
thought of going overseas as exciting
for me i think
um
i have a family now and i think
goals and things change
so obviously
you know enjoying where i am playing
rugby as number one but also
doing what's best for my family and
being able to
provide for them
and also to give my family a cool
experience somewhere overseas whether it
be over in europe or japan
i think those will be pretty cool
memories that you can make with your
family and
you know you only look at other boys
that have done it as well you know like
a bender and
you know andy ellis was over there and
desi was over there and a lot of guys
that have gone over there with a family
and just
created
such great uh experiences 100 and life
after rugby have you thought that far
ahead what have you got planned i know
you're doing a lot of modeling jockey
replay denim with the yeah
real good um shoots back uh oh mate to
be fair i'm not too sure it's
it's a tough one i think one thing i do
know is that
it'll be
probably involved in footy i think yeah
maybe being an agent would be quite cool
for me um
i have an agent who
who used to play rugby who kind of gets
it and i feel like
that's a crucial part of being an agent
where
i've experienced both sides where
you know you get looked after someone
that might not get it or
doesn't understand it fully and then
i think it'll be pretty cool to be
helpful to players that can come across
problems and solve problems that you've
been through yourself you know
the likes of financial advice and
pressures of rugby
and also
looking after them in terms of
sponsorship deals and stuff like that so
i think that'll be
maybe
one thing but
i i would always say i didn't want to go
down the coaching
coaching or commentating way but
yeah who knows if um if i get pretty
desperate i might have to start putting
the whistle around my neck
mate you'd be a bloody good player agent
oh geez i'm sure a lot of people would
like to be looked after by you
it's a hell of a career yeah i'm not too
sure if i have half these sponsorship
deals i have now so that could be a big
problem but
um
but you know i don't know brownies
mattress man you know if you're looking
for brownies uh if you're looking for a
mattress yourself you know you can you
can kick your old bed into touch mate
and brownies will find a bed for you
mate
oh you're good there's your job lifetime
ambassador for brownies
i hope so man you gotta play that one
for them
but you do have all sorts of sponsorship
um deals don't you yeah you're running
all sorts of deals and um
you know you're a big influencer i guess
it's cool these days but how do you find
that side of your rugby life
i find it rewarding bro i think it's
cool um
you know you don't want to be that guy
that's on on the back of everything and
um he's got his fingers in all these
pies and you're that guy that's what
them and that person but
um said i like it because it's rewarding
of the work you do you know and it's
um
you know i guess one of the main reasons
you know is because you know i'm head of
perks committee uh with the crusaders
and uh
no i've actually i've actually been i've
actually been um demoted of will jordan
now because
he had such an awesome year last year
he's actually head of perks committee
but i'm more of his assistant
and um you know as much freebies as we
can give the boys as possible it's just
it just keeps things rolling and it's a
big part of
our team perks committee
mate i could imagine the perks coming in
from you and will could be through the
road
yeah we're working on on on giving the
house away to one of the boys
but um that's in the pipeline i'm not
too sure when that will happen but we're
working on that
oh good he'll be lining up he's been
looking for years isn't it
i think he's just found one but
yeah he's probably most deserving oh
goody um
yeah he's he's definitely most deserving
that's for sure
right well as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and i do
say it all the time that i get heaps of
questions but mate literally i reckon
this is a new pb so many questions from
so many people all around the world
a question that came up a heap this
first question was about the nrl i know
geordi mentioned it um on his waterlab
podcast and it sort of blew out a wee
bit but would you ever consider playing
nrl
oh bro for sure man i'd love to um
you know i'd probably say i'll watch
more nrl than i do super rugby but yeah
um
you know it's just something that you
know you always sort of imagine yourself
doing you kind of wonder like you know
what what would it be like how would i
go
um
but i'll definitely give it a crack
do i think i'll be good i actually i
don't think i would have you know the
same influence or the same impact i'd do
on footy to be honest
but the likes of geordie man and
i like some of those other guys those
guys would definitely be would
definitely be gun league players would
you see yourself as a seven
yeah yeah i'd be in the hearts man um
yeah you know the old short ball out the
back i think they would you know deadly
short kicking game
dead yeah
short kicking game not too sure how my
crosstakes would go but
um
it would be cool it would be cool to
experience it but
i don't think i'd be any good to be
honest how do you reckon a all black
league side would go against
an nrl team
bro to be honest i
you know i'd want to say would go good
but
i just think
um
people that
maybe they have this position that
league is kind of easy to play you know
because you roll the ball there's
there's not much to it but
i'd say because of just how much i know
is
strategically and how taxing it is on
their wrestling
there's all that the gripping they do
um
speed of the ruck
i just think we'll get smashed to be
honest to be fair
i think yeah mate that's a you make a
good case there i think people don't
give it enough credit as it deserves
they like they run some lines all their
shapes and stuff
no i honestly no they don't borrow they
don't and i think you know people will
say this person would be a main league
player but
um you know there's so much to it you
know and i'm saying that i haven't even
played league i just kind of could
imagine
the line running
um
you know and and and all that jazz
um
what i do know is i'll probably you move
to the wing on defense because some of
those boys are massive
[Laughter]
some of those boys are massive eh you
know you get a big nelson running down
your channel
um
yeah you know
there's a big boy and those hookers and
guys are making
ridiculous amounts of tackles
that's exciting though geordie and
richie in the half
yeah get the old
mad butcher and uh
get in there get him in there be awesome
you're always looking for deals
[Laughter]
this is one i can't crack on as is uh
you know the me sort of some sort of
meat company yeah that's what i'm
working on for the lads
oh mate i'm sure dan perrin at nelson
mad butcher will um sort yeah
surely okay next question who shapes
your goatee tamari allison
somebody alison
wow that's that's that's interesting i
actually um yeah my barber does it for
me
all the shaping of my goatees and and
all my beds
i think he's just angry one time i
caught him out on his because
he went for something a bit different
he went for something a bit thin
along here and i just sort of called him
out on it
um
so i think he's a bit he's a bit sour at
that comment
i don't actually didn't know it hit him
that hard that he had to sort of jump on
what allowed to
put a put a question out there about it
sorry sorry tom holy echo oh you got him
deep
i got him deep man
okay next one from another good lad
sitter tamina values tell the story
about when he nearly got a hiding from a
parking warden in the morning of the
2018 finals
oh man
yeah that's a funny story that's
actually one i i've kind of forgotten
about um
but we go to this one cafe before um
on game day you know for a brunch
we go to we go to one and it's in
maryvale bridget's and
there's a mcdonald's behind it and you
know how sometimes you're real strict
about you can't park in the mcdonald's
and go over there or whatever
so that you know they're they're that
strict where they have this one parking
warden who actually is looking for guys
that are parking in mcdonald's and
aren't going into mcdonald's
so we parked in mecca's anyway we ran
around the wrong way
and uh as well coming back to go the car
after brunch
he just wasn't happy eh
and um
you know being the sort of smart ass i
am like i was um
i was kind of just saying it wasn't nice
it wasn't us
and there was a car trying to get out
but he was telling us off
and i was like sir watch out the car is
gonna hurt you sir please watch out i
was just being i was being a dick
and um he turned around to me and he
said oh shut up
and uh i honestly thought i thought he
was going to give me high dna to be fair
but it was at that moment i sort of i
just like that so he's gonna um he's
gonna karate chop me i reckon so
that was that story it was you know
kind of the ones you had to sort of be
there um to sort of get it
um
what i'm probably more surprised about
is that you could read sets as um
his message
you kind of probably had to sort of get
a translator to
to make sure that that's what he was
saying but
that was a good memory yeah he's got
good memory big setter he he loves a
good yarn a big man but he does yeah
you're right i did have to
reword it a little bit
but speaking of what's the next question
uh next question was you're a huge fight
you're a huge fight sports fan would you
consider doing mma or boxing during or
post footy
oh man
bro probably not a i think
i'll probably think i'd be like top
three in new zealand of like shadow
boxing
like i'd be up there
[Laughter]
like honestly bro you should see my
shadow boxing it's like
everything just looks um it's poultry
motion but
it's mayweather like some have said that
um you know not my words but
to be fair like i just um
i'm probably just too scared to get hit
hey um
but i do love i do love the combat you
know the combat sport man ufc and boxing
um
always been into it since i was little
and just sort of love that
um
i love sort of the what they go through
as athletes and
i think there can't be any more sort of
daunting and you know scary then being
in a ring
putting yourself out there and throwing
hands man and i think
that's why i love it so much because of
the fighters that i watch and the
fighters that i follow on instagram like
their mindset is just different and
i think um you know once people
understand what they actually go through
they'll give that
sport a bigger appreciation
maybe they should try and get you in the
ring for a fight for life shadow boxing
that would be good to watch
but if we could like somehow like have
pillows as as gloves
like i'm all for man you know
[Music]
but yeah i think some of the boys at
training get annoyed because you know
i'll be in the corner and all you could
hear is
um and i'm just over there throwing
combos
um
but it is funny some of the boys get
real annoyed oh that's classic okay next
one would you ever play for tonga oh
yeah for sure man i
i definitely would i think even
before rules rule changes and before
combo's about
you know
possible teams
um
you know i wanted to play for
um the tongan league team you know
seeing their success over the years and
their success over tier one nations
and just how they could
um you know bring a country together was
pretty inspiring for me
and and taking pay cuts and whatnot and
and um just the honor and the
what a privilege it was for them to put
a tongan jersey on was pretty special so
i always thought if i did move to league
or if i did play a league i always
wanted to play um for tonga
and league true what about union the
three-year stand down post all black
career yeah bro yep definitely i yeah
definitely although i'm someone too so
um
yeah someone told i would definitely
play for them i'm not too sure which one
i would play for but what would decide
that um
probably who's going better at the time
[Laughter]
probably the ford packs would decide
that bro i don't know
um
no i i'd say my gut says i'd play for
thomas that's um
you know with in my family it's
um
you know we've had more of a tongan
upbringing and
um we've sort of indulged more in our
tongan culture to be fair so
yeah oh tongan community will be happy
to hear that that's good stuff okay next
question thoughts on geordie bear
outside you at 12. um
man what what people don't know is that
he's actually we've played some games of
me at 10 and him at 12 for canterbury um
that's right
when he was just a young lad out of um
you know lincoln uni he was playing 12
and man he's um
yeah i think that
you know as i think wherever he plays
bro he's he's world class
and i think um
his size at 12 is going to be
is going to be awesome you know i
thought
just his physicality as well
uh you lose nothing in a playmaker he's
he's a playmaker he's a kicker he's
um he's he's world class so
you could put him at censor he'd be
awesome yeah you put him anywhere i
reckon he's he's world class i agree
yeah
and this question we're gonna i feel
like i'm gonna get every week until um
we start seeing and play but
thoughts on roger two of us
at 12. oh deadly bro i think he's going
to be awesome man um
you just kind of know i think
i think you kind of just have to
have seen his leg career and what he's
done at every you know
with the roosters and at the warriors
and
um
he hasn't always been behind good teams
at the warriors but
one thing you know when you're watching
the warriors is that he's the best
player on the field like it's just
it's crazy the influence that he has on
his team especially when he's in a
losing team or he's in a team that's
losing by 20 it just doesn't seem to
phase him
and i think that's
you know
it's probably been the only thing you
know
keeping me watching the worries was him
when he was here
[Music]
amongst all the hard times and
but yeah i think he's going to go good
and i do hope he goes good you know he's
someone that will just make
the best out of out of everything he
gets so yeah it's cool to see guys come
from league over
yeah yeah and i hope it happens you know
more often and it happens the other way
too yeah one thing i'm actually really
glad about is they put
him at 12 and not rico at 12
because um i don't think i don't think
how roger would have seen any ball if he
was playing 13 and rico was paying 12a
i'm probably yeah that's probably just
that's probably the best outcome already
so
he's already uh he's really doing well
oh good stuff okay next one what's your
quad workout we got this one a few times
i didn't even notice how big your quads
were but a lot of feedback on how nice
your quads are
like it's that or it could be how small
the shorts are that's that's the other
thing that people don't seem to think
about secretion that's the same i wish i
knew that i would have wore triple t
excess yeah and that's it um
you know another one is a luke
mccullough say you know you
big hype around his legs but
people don't realize he was actually
wearing so small shorts
really
no that's a yarn i actually just love um
that's the yarn uh no i got tiny legs
man but i do love
the gym
um
i love my lifting and love the sort of
how technical it is in terms of like a
clean jerk or snatch or
sort of body movements and stuff
um i kind of have to be careful who i
talk you know who i talk to about that
sort of stuff because it's
it can be really boring to some people
way or they kind of wonder
why are you watching videos of someone
lifting all the time
but that yeah that was probably an
influence that owen frank's had on me so
yeah oh true because owen frank says
your brother-in-law right
yeah bro yep yeah he's my brother-in-law
yeah how's what's that relationship like
um
bro it's cool man it's um
you know he was actually a huge part in
and me
you know
being where i am now uh when i left
school
and you know when i was playing film
with seniors i was living with owen at
the time
and before
we knew each other through our wives
um
he knew my older brothers uh they went
to crush this was high too so
you know we'd cross piles and you know i
was too small to sort of to talk with
him want to sort of get to know him but
um
but
we just kind of uh vibed that way and
i was off to work on a scooter like
at 7 00 am
going concreting and he was off to to go
train for the crusaders and he was
living his
he was living my dream too so i was able
to see that
you know daily of what you know ultimate
professional look like um
and because it was so close and because
someone in the same house was doing that
it just
it made it so real that i could possibly
maybe be his teammate or
or be
you know be a professional rugby player
one day and there's not too many more
professional guys than the frank's
brothers they they uh they were always
next level in their preparation yeah and
professionalism
yeah what i realized is that you know he
was the exception and in terms of you
know i was seeing what he was eating and
his daily routines and
how professional he was and
um
yeah he is world-class man no one
doesn't like him and you talk to anyone
in the rugby environment in new zealand
um
they all say the same thing about owie
and his work ethic and just as uh you
know the sacrifice and how dedicated he
is
hundred percent okay next one
in your opinion top three tens of all
time
um
one daniel carter
two johnny wilkinson
and three
um
three
i'd have to say
can be yourself i was
i was a big larkin fan but
um
i have to say uh carlos spencer oh yeah
yeah all different players but
carlos was very creative and the way he
was you know doing things in that time
in the area that he was era he was
playing and which no one had seen before
which sort of just inspired me to sort
of be creative you know and sort
of um
yeah it was cool it was cool to watch
that i'd say those three yeah
nice okay next one surely some chat
around his involvement in the horse game
i know you're part owner of a champion
horse uh yeah it's um
to be fair like i i
i didn't grow up watching horses or or
um
i didn't know too much about the you
know the racing industry but uh we're
just real lucky to
to have a horse named after me really
that that's how that's sort of as simple
as that the horse named after me
um he was over in sydney
um he was looking you know pretty good
and
um the 10 that i own just goes to child
cancer foundation which is
um a foundation and charity that i'm an
ambassador for
um
and one that i think you know um as well
deserving of all the winnings that
monger gets so
that's my small involvement and
as well as you know watching every
saturday and having a wee pun
that's awesome you're the horse that's
named after you turns out to be a
champion it's always disappointing when
they name one and it
turns out to be a donkey but
they've named it and it turns out to
have the goods yeah well man he's hoping
for another good season um
yeah mom has had a pretty good
pre-season from what i've heard and uh
he's looking in good nick
and um just waiting for the return and
you know it's pretty special to watch
you know when you're involved in it it's
named after yourself but even when
you're turning it on to
you know for for winnings to go to such
a good charity and
you know yeah um something like chad
child cancer foundation that sort of
makes it
a lot better
matt you're such a good lad love that
okay next one this one's from your
analysis jg most influential player in
new zealand rugby and this again can be
yourself
um
i have two
oh i have three i i'd say
i'd say
in new zealand i'd say the three most
influential players uh
uh aaron smith
um idi savea and geordie barrett nice
i'd probably say at the moment i'd
probably say geordie barrett is the most
influential player yeah um
i just sort of love the i don't know the
way he wears his heart on his sleeve and
he's such a just
his aggression and his um
you know i've been around him to know
that
he doesn't like losing and even to watch
the game in the weekend
you see how special he is as a player
and what he's willing to do to
to win the game or or if he's not
winning the game what he's willing to do
to try and hurt someone which is quite
it's quite funny to watch that tackle on
leicester oh it took a big hard shot to
stop leicester five minutes from the
line
man honestly and that's
it's not surprising you know when you
know jordy and you know him well too
um
you know actions like that and things
like that he's just um
you know and being the
the little brother of a you know bodhian
scooter
um
yeah he's probably had to deal with a
lot growing up to
to overcome some obstacles
you can you can see it man and it's uh
that's what makes geordie jordy and
that's uh
that's why he's the man
that's an alert okay last question
one piece of advice you have for our
listeners
oh well always love ending on a
inspirational wow ah no pressure i think
um
i don't know
i don't know
i don't have a quote as such i think um
just i guess your mindset and your
attitude i think
um you know seeing the best and shitty
situations
um having a different perspective
always helps and always sort of
what it gives you an understanding of
where you really are and what you really
have and what really matters and i think
it's the cool thing about it
um right so yeah that's probably it's
probably really disappointing now i'm
sorry man that was
yeah sorry about that i actually loved
it i thought it was awesome because mate
you live by that and hearing your story
it feels like your whole your whole
career has been around that like you've
had you had confidence as a young fellow
you always thought you're going to
become who you are today and that's so
cool to hear and it's all been around
based on your mindset like you just
spoke about in your advice so
you might not have felt it was good but
that was one of the best thanks fella
thanks for
thanks for the wii pump up
my absolute pleasure to have have you on
the podcast mate like um it's great to
sit down with one of the greats and go
through your journey i know you're still
so young so still plenty left
in your rugby career which i'm really
looking forward to watching as well so
i'm looking forward to seeing you back
out there with the crusaders i'm not
that they need any help but mate no
doubt you're going to make a massive
difference for them and i'm looking
forward to seeing you
back out there running the cutter so
appreciate you coming on the podcast
mate
thanks brother thanks for having me bro
you're a lad